comment ça va l'association fait ça là
bas ça cartonne toujours autant là le
truc à faire conclut la qui aurait cru
que la brocante salle est comme ça tout
péter qua non mais sans rigoler c'est
incroyable quoi tu amènes 3 oblige il
est là et c'est parti et d'efforts pour
cent de parts de marché 10 millions
téléspectateurs et bam bam boum et des
rediff à foison sophie davant c'est la
nana de france on la voit toute la
journée
mon frère c'est un truc de fou ça va se
ressentir l'après midi ouais bah oui
l'après midi vous n'arrêtez pas aussi
serré que le matin ils ont arrêtés sont
au programme pour des raisons
budgétaires mais vous allez récupérer un
prime time sur france franchement là
vous avez appelé tout le monde et la
vente est alors devenue maintenant c'est
vrai que j'ai rappelé le patron de
france télévisions cas qui sont dits la
patronne des divertissements alexandra
bas à miel c'est vrai qu'on marque par
les images les séries c'est fou parce
que et moi sorte en émission j'ai eu un
texto de franck sera donc le producteur
mon futur producteur et quand on l'a dit
mais c'est une excellente idée avant
avant que les lieux tant alexandra me
rappelle franck saurat c'est vrai le
producteur et alexandra donc la dirai
que c'est grâce à vous franchement tu es
vous prendre comme personnel écoute avec
ont plusieurs
qu'est ce qu'il ya elle est où la part
financière pour vous alors je vais ça
gratuitement pour le bien de la
télévision française
[Applaudissements]
alexandra n'da c8 je t'appelle chez un
petit peu emmerdé 1
concernant la petite d'avant là bah
ouais parce que là on lui a arrêté sept
au programme la lof
elle a envie de faire d'autres donc elle
me dit qu'elle serait chaude sur lui
samedi soir
si tu pouvais du blog qu'il débloquait
une douzaine de preuves ça nous
arrangerait tu as un producteur non
alors là pas de conducteur
[Applaudissements]
celle ci est donc cette émission va voir
le jour
cela sape le mal-être ou est ce que je
fais c'est ce que je peux vous demander
de truquer tout ce que vous dites moi
voulait quelque chose
il ya eu trop ménager merci lisait
devant un mini hachoir sait recevoir un
robot un match hynix je suis là mais ce
qu'elle veut
s'ensuit donc l or donc cette émission
va voir le jour qui font que je connais
bien
vous êtes toujours attiré par sophie bas
mais j'ai l'impression que ça peu à sens
unique ce témoin oui c'est vrai je vous
le confirme pas parce que ça fait quand
même disons que ça lui au jour elle
était venue sur la paix la première à
dire les choses en disant mais là on a
pris du retard
la célèbre l'humour c'est mal barré
justement sophie il ya quelques temps
vous disiez dans les grosses têtes
quel est ce qu'elle est et les qualités
pour vous séduire non mais c'est vrai
vous disiez ça et je m'en rappelle pas
c'est quoi il faut qu'un homme est quoi
pour vous séduire avec qui vous avez dit
qu'il faut qu'il soit intelligent
si si non mais c'est vrai il fait
surtout il faut surtout qu'il soit
intelligent intelligent
ouais intelligent drôle curieux
attentionné away généreux ah ouais merde
vendu entendu c'est un bon vous avez
vous avez dû piler une bête au tien le
bateau ça va quand je dis qu'il me vais
te fous qui fut un bateau c'est mieux
bah oui bon c'est moi
ces nouvelles cartes une barquette trois
japonais n'ont pas tous dans bateau
jorat de pêcheurs non académique mais
qu'il est moche
alors forcément c'est pas forcément mon
premier critère c'est ça m'a largué
charme
en fait depuis ce charme que le suel
j'ai vu c'est pas moi en tout cas non
mais bon là c'est en tout cas sophie il
manque le bateau ça c'est rien vous
inquiétez pas un petit bateau à moteur
c'est rien du tout on va démarrer alors
on va faire un jeu c'est un homme un
objet vous propose ou un objet puisque
vous êtes ou un homme
voilà on va démarrer par la deuxième pas
la première la deuxième la deuxième
alors quelle bonne affaire
choisissez-vous entre une lampe
champignons donnant si estimé à 8000
euros ou une semaine au club med de
djerba la douce avec pierre niney dans
vos bagages en fut alors c'est des
objets qui ont été vendus dans votre
émission
je prends la lente parce que je pense
que c'est plus durable
alors vous avez travaillé longtemps avec
williams qui est maintenant chez nous et
ce qui vous manque
oui ce que c'est que tu es votre
producteur et c'est vrai que voilà nous
inonder très il est très bien chez nous
ça monte de plus en plus d'ailleurs les
audiences de william ça cartonne
et c'est vrai que tous les ministres
puissent de complicité au quotidien
c'est bah ouais bah c'est comme moi et
benhaim à beinheim quand elle est sans
moi aller comme un chien fou il saute
partie les camions non mais c'est vrai
ben c'est quand même vrai dena voilà
c'est cette année 6 1 alors quelles
bonnes affaires se dit c'est votre un
hochet en nacre daté de napoléon iii
d'une valeur de 350 euros ou un week end
à poules mais qu'avec chez william
leymergie sans hésiter le week-end chez
williams ah bah oui là-bas si tu nous
regardes williams voit la walkyrie
m'embêter tu peux c'est vrai très bien
et il y avait il ya veille avait pas
rocher on a cru d'athéna paulo ainsi en
avait 1 parce que j'ai failli accoucher
chez lui donc c'est vrai il ya une
alchimie savez la feuille à coucher où
il en émerge une censure son tapis
devant la télé ouais ouais quand même
et c'est pas lui le père j'ai planté
mais il pourrait que tout faire à
william un peu et dont il peut faire
sache pas bon je connais qu'elle voit
d'affaires choisissez-vous en trois
passages piétons lumineux des années 70
estimés à 80 euros qui a été vendu non
voilà dans votre émission où une soirée
au flunch légumes à volonté plus si
affinités avec laurent delahousse a
quand même
il a des chaussures bateau des dockside
non là j'irai chez flunch quoi de là où
c'est ce que j'aime bien discuter avec
free adacore je croyais oui c'est vrai
oui c'est la basse et il est pas mal
about uc fini à beinheim ça pourrait
être utile je suis pas très blond mois
mais oui sinon il est pas mal
alors attention quelle bonne affaire
choisissez-vous entre un luth d'afrique
de l'ouest fabriqué en peau de veau
d'une valeur de 20 euros ou une soit le
au méga macumba de bordeaux avec jean
michel maire en guest star
les
[Applaudissements]
jeudi il a fait du sport tout l'été sur
la plage ou d'un banal s'il vous plaît
aidez-nous louvoyer pas vous donner des
petits yeux alors je choisis jean michel
maire à condition qu'ils ont emmené sur
le bassin d'arcachon sur un voilier
après cette célibataire
exact eh ben j'ai envie de dire affaire
conclue
le sauve moi franchement je regrette
déjà c'est un peu la meuf donc tout le
monde rêve elle est sympathique sexy
elle est sexy et elle s'implique vous
avez toujours des fous rires dans votre
émission vois que vous amusez vous aviez
découvrir dans c'est au programme on a
faim top 3 des fous rires d'affaires
conclut vous avez un fou rire en
critiquant une oeuvre d'art sauf que
vous n'aviez pas compris que l'artiste
était juste à côté
c'est un grand moment d'affaires conclut
regardez vous avez montré la caméra cgu
l'esa je suis pas s'il était tellement
doué quand même pour l'air pour les tête
d'éléphant
non mais c'est c'est monsieur guerlain
ce cri bien bien je dois à la corde et a
joué au pin l'accord je suis pas patron
[Applaudissements]
je peux dire c'était c'est un format
allemands à faire conclut mme may sophie
a porté sa bonne humeur son humour a pas
que votre femme est allemand oui oui oui
à mag en séries tu l'as bien mérité sa
cousine vérité mérite oui et donc sa
bonne humeur son sens de la répartie
mais tu crois que tu crois qu'on
allemagne frères l'animateur de clariant
et ne confond le référé droit mon frérot
tout le monde est comme ça même
l'animatrice allemande
[Musique]
il a une moustache là-bas kouteiba déjà
ça donne envie tu vois travailler pour
les q6 wydad en deuxième position
commence avec un fou rire due à une
experte assez maladroite regarder si
vous avez envie d'aller vous balader et
bien vous prenez votre petit truc là
voilà
[Musique]
et vous allez vas-y content mes
cassettes il dit son cas c'est sûr que
c'est sûr que c'est sûr je suis désolé
ouais je vais vous en trouvez parce
qu'on en a énormément dans les ventes
aux enchères
je vous promets de vous regardez votre
petite fille pouvoir sexuel
qu'est ce qu'on croit j'adore cette
émission avec supprime deux dans chaque
fois je regarde j'ai envie de vous
amener des objets moi j'ai plein
d'autres souches mois chez moi sans quoi
ils sont jugés très cru que ça touche en
disant ça veut dire c'est des noblian
fait il s'en sert jamais assez que
touchent des babioles je vais d amener
100 mdsy à ce jour j'ai besoin parce que
après on les donnera ce soir mais j'ai
besoin m'a donné une association après
des mois valait d'être chaude sans
battre alors cedex ou je décide de faire
ça merci tout cas très bonnes
interventions pas bon et on numéro un le
fou rire est due à une levrette mal
placé ne vous inquiétez pas il n'y a
rien de sexuel
non je vous jure n'y a rien de sexuel
sauf et vous rappeler cet extrait au oui
je vois à peu près ça les regarde en
bronze de belle qualité avec une belle
patine et c'est vraiment une jolie
levrette vraiment elle elle est bien
réalisé c'est à lévriers alors tout
dépend de quelle taille et le chien vous
vous l'imaginez de quelle taille ce
chien si les cette taille c'est une
petite levrette de plus de fruits les
plus grands c'est aller briller leur
faim
oui c'est moi je préfère honnêtement je
préfère qu'ils soient au ça m'arrange
[Applaudissements]
elles peuvent y aller ça passe ça passe
franchement ça passe non mais c'est ça
vous êtes trans deux dents parce que sur
france 2 on peut se dire voilà mais
c'est c'est tranquille
l effet avec chic bien sûr avec chic us
alors demain vous serez de rainsars
seront accueillis à partir de 21h05 sur
france 2 après ma l'occasion des
journées du patrimoine suivie d'une
nouvelle émission présentée par sophie
davant
affaire conclue de duel des brocantes
alors il faut savoir que dentaire conclu
vous avez vu passer spin off
ouais c'est ça 2 1 et 2 et vous avez
fait vous avez quelques surprises le 28
avril 2019 par exemple d'une vendeuse
qu'a proposé 16 dessins signés de
jacqueline roque et pablo picasso qui
ont été vendus à 1909 1300 euros ce qui
est le record pour l'émission
voilà c'est un truc de ouf regardez ça
on a le on a l'eau on a le tableau on
fait des trucs voilà et sa part un ben
voilà donc voilà donc ça a été vendu
1000 9300 euros
il ya aussi des objets un peu moins si
les parents vous avez vous reçu en mars
dernier une vendeuse qui est venu vous
proposer une poupée la poupée elle fait
robe de ouf on faire cette poupée chez
wordpress est la maison prend feu il ya
des trucs chelous jean reuilles il ya un
rocking chair d'abattoirs la poupée elle
t'a pas te port le soir
ah non mais c'est un truc de ouf cette
poupée la vraie elle a été vendue 80
euros à moi-même et mes 80 euros pour
avoir là une maison hantée alors
messieurs c'est patrizia ciofi mais il
ya des poupées qui font des records de
vente un des poupées anciennes
alors simple avec sa dalle c'est très
beau c'est celle là elle devait avoir
des petits problèmes
elle a des tout petits dés tout c'est la
poupée casta alors merci des objections
la personne ne sait pourquoi en février
2019 ya un vendeur qui a ramené un objet
que personne n'a reconnu mais qui a
quand même été achetés regardez alors ça
on sait pas du tout ce que c'est c'est
quoi ça va faire étape c'est quoi oui
1-2 crapoteux bien non ça va au niveau
des primes non merci
normal mais je crois qu'on n'a pas
trouvé les ja on n'a jamais trouvé à toi
bien servi et ce même ça
cet objet y faire autant elle amène sa
chez toi avec la poupée par ses amitiés
mais c'est à la sans rigoler c'est le
début d'un film d'horreur
tu connais tout allait bien quand la
famille spence et arrive dans sa
nouvelle demeure un réel effet la tuque
non pas les films d'horreur ça commence
tu l'auras elle fuit venant jamais
prolongé sur loup à la poupée way
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qui se passe to be est mort
regardez ah oui c'est tout fait avec la
poupée barbie sauriez et là ça commence
qu'à et reviennent à la maison
les fortes se ferment tout seul il ya
des mouches cammas de tout part dans les
films d'horreur il ya toujours des
mouches et à la ligue 1 quand mon frère
tu as peur des mouches dans les films
d'horreur c'est le seul truc où le
moment pour te faire gratuitement des
mouches ferait à moyens une mouche qu'on
ne dise pas grave car c'est pas un film
d'horreur
ils mettent des mouches partout ah non
mais je vous jure il ya des objets chez
louvroil et les geôliers qui me font
peur vous avez vous étiez dans une
maison hantée je sais et d'ailleurs je
sais vous étiez vous aviez un fantôme
oui et je me rappelle c'était un fantôme
qui faisait baisser la vue c'était
afflelou il a un autre objet qu'on a vu
il ya quoi dahouët ya quoi ah ouais bah
non madame yade celui-là et ben merci
merci sophy salut je voulais poser une
question à sophie il paraît qu'ils
achètent vraiment les les objets avec
leur argent les mêmes jury qu'est ce
qu'ils en font d'ailleurs un bénéfice
sur les achats qui met pas tous parce
que par exemple sergent c'est un
collectionneur et lui ne les revend pas
que moi c'est ça mais sinon oui ils font
du militaire une hachette et vraiment
s'y retrouve benjamin c'est pas une
critique j'aimerais jouer savoir si
derrière ce qu'il dit est vrai que tout
le monde est content l'émission de
sophie a multiplié la casse par 666% non
monstrueux celle ci c'est énorme c'est
le diable
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est beaucoup alors sophie il y aura
donc un prime de m'asseoir on va voir la
bande-annonce est juste après on va se
retrouver ici je vous le dis là dans une
danse une seconde latte en 30 secondes
et on va faire un jeu ensemble qui va
s'appeler tripoter c'est gagné vous avez
acquis des connaissances en matière
d'objets je vous proposais de jouer à
retrouver des objets sans les voir mais
juste en les touchant ses moyens et vous
allez voir on a on a des trucs
exceptionnel on va voir si vous êtes
vraiment exceptionnel et calais en
matière d'objets pour garder sinon c'est
demain soir sur france2 regard des
bonnes avec moi sophie bonnet bonjour à
tous et bienvenue pour cette émission
exceptionnelle ici sur le site de la
mine de oignies à l'occasion des
journées du patrimoine
à l'occasion de cette émission spéciale
des particuliers venus des quatre coins
de la france m'ont présenté en public
leurs objets à nos commissaires priseurs
avant de rencontrer nos acheteurs
un monument de l'histoire de l'histoire
politique un tableau de qualité ça
fonctionne bien
parmi nos vendeurs des personnalités
sont venues proposer des objets qui
leurs sont chers pour soutenir des
associations
c'est magnifique douze oeuvres 25000
euros maintenant je vous avoue que j'ai
un tout petit peu le vertige quand même
bienvenu pour cette soirée
exceptionnelle d'affaires compris
[Musique]
quatre complices et demain soir sur
france 2 m c'est la vérité le soir à
21h05